[Music]
Tet Offensive My Lai massacre
assassinations of Martin Luther King jr.
and Robert Kennedy Democratic convention
in Chicago Prague Spring and its
backlash mark Kerr Lansky examines the
momentous events of 1968 in his latest
work this week's history on Bob TV
feature is an hour thank you all very
much this is not a primary and
everything is non-binding in in a
writer's life there are books that just
come out very suddenly and there are
other books that come out through a lot
of reflection and a very slow process
this book is the second kind I first
started discussing it with my editor
over ten years ago I think I first
started trying to make sense out of 1968
in 1969 certainly I spent a lot of the
70s
thinking about it what was that what
happened what did it mean what did it
lead to where is it gone I spent the
whole 1970s wondering what was going to
happen next and there was his feeling
that nothing was happening next and then
in the 1980s I remember thinking well no
this can't be it
1968 was a unique year in history a year
in which there were social explosions
mainly not but not entirely from student
movements in most countries in the world
and the interesting thing about this is
that these countries did not really have
a lot in common and certainly didn't
have
these explosions were not over the same
issues if you think about communist
Poland in Czechoslovakia and France
under de Gaulle and Germany and Italy
and Spain which was still under Franco
and the United States and Mexico and
Japan totally different issues and yet
people doing almost the same things
acting in the same way at exactly the
same time and not having much contact
with each other and they didn't know
each other
the people who led these movements first
of all there weren't many leaders in a
characteristic that all these movements
had in common is that the few people
that you might be able to identify as
leaders denied that they were leaders
because they were all anti-authoritarian
and therefore anti anti leadership
movement so they were anti leader
leaders and in 1968 it was a very big
deal to make an international phone call
people just were not in contact with
people from other countries very much
and although certain frustrated
government leaders such as de Gaulle in
France and the afford often Mexico
looked at events and not without logic
concluded that there was some sort of a
world conspiracy that was just you know
had a checklist and was going from
country to country it was understandable
that somebody could think that because
you know Poland explodes and just as it
dies down
Germany explodes and just as it dies
down Italy goes and then France and then
some university in the US and it's so
the whole year went but not through any
kind of organization at all so I I tried
to understand what the factors were that
were that were causing this to happen
and of course the first factor that was
so much talked about at the time was the
generation gap in the words of Grayson
Couric at Columbia the fact that people
of my age people I was born in 1948 I
turned 20 in 1968 people born after
World War 2 just did not see things the
way people born before World War two did
I don't think there has ever been a time
in human history where there's been two
generations who saw things so completely
differently there is nothing like that
kind of distance today I say hopefully
because I'm a parent the recently III I
heard one of the Lyndon Johnson's tapes
in which he made this statement the only
choice I had was between appeasement and
war I mean that that is a voice from the
1930s that made no sense to me in the
1960s that made no sense in a world with
nuclear weapons nuclear weapons were one
of the things that made people of my
generation see things very differently
I remember the entire time I was growing
up being obsessed by this idea that
there were these weapons that were going
to destroy the world
I vividly remember the Cuban Missile
Crisis
not at all the way is often talked about
today about you know John Kennedy
masterfully getting the Soviets to back
down and so we were protected what I
remember is these crazy people John
Kennedy Nikita Khrushchev they're
playing poker trying to decide whether
or not they should destroy life on the
planet as we know it I remember being
really really scared and also really
angry I remember hiding under desks and
being taught how to you know cover up in
the event of nuclear attack I mean are
crouching down in hallways like this and
thinking you think this is gonna work
and people in Hungary and Czechoslovakia
and Poland were doing the exact same
thing and and feeling the exact same way
about it the Holocaust had a huge impact
on my generation not just among Jewish
people but among all kinds of people all
over the world because what Nazi Germany
showed was the price of a lack of
political activism what happens if when
things start going wrong nobody says
anything that was this this lesson that
was overwhelming to the post-world war
two people that you know things go wrong
you don't say anything well they didn't
say anything in Germany and look what
happened it was very striking to me when
I was working on this book and going to
other countries and and meeting with
student leaders and students people who
were active in their countries whose
experiences really were nothing like
somebody like Adam Michnik who spent
many years of his youth in prison and
communist Poland because he protested or
you know people in Mexico who saw all of
their friends killed and yet you know I
went and talked to these people and they
were all my age and we had so much in
common we saw so many things in the in
the same way it was just tremendously
striking even now 35 years later one of
the other factors was the civil rights
movement which had been going on for
more than ten years by 1968 and had
gotten pretty savvy about how to get on
television and was seen all over the
world and these people who went down to
Mississippi were tremendous heroes to a
lot of us and everybody was intrigued by
the things they did and and the things
that they invented in the creativity of
concepts like God sit-ins and people
felt you know that this is what you do I
mean but the people wanted to be like
civil rights workers so that when the
Polish government closed down to play in
Warsaw and the students the Warsaw
students wanted to do something to
protest they said let's have a sit-in
and then there was this whole discussion
over yeah okay what do we do now do we I
guess we're supposed to sit down you
know they weren't really sure what it
was but they knew it was it was
something that had been done in the
civil rights movement and it
was one of the ways in which you
protested protest was in the air he
protested everything most of the
important student movements of 68
started and relatively small issues the
first the first demonstration in Prague
was over badly lit dormitories the
French student movement began over
co-educational dormitories in Mexico it
began over a fight between rival high
schools but what invariably happened was
that these demonstrations would be put
down violently and then the official
repression became the issue and they
would grow from there
Marc Rudd the SDS leader at Columbia in
68 said the issue is not the issue
actually I I saw Marc recently and he
said that he really liked the book but
his one problem was you know when you
said the issue is not the issue you had
it backwards 68 humor another thing that
made all of these things grow all over
the world was the Vietnam War 1968 was
the year the worst year of the Vietnam
War and every week the US military was
killing in Vietnam more people than died
in the September 11th attack and this
was an age that this was still the age
of decolonization when new countries
were emerging breaking away from
colonial powers and to all of the world
except the Johnson and
that's what Vietnam was also was a
country trying to get its independence
and to the Johnson administration it was
a a step in the in a communist world
plot to take over almost nobody else in
the world saw it that way and in many
countries including France Germany
Mexico demonstrations were fairly small
until they became demonstrations about
the American war in Vietnam
you could always you could always
everywhere get huge numbers to
demonstrate against the American war in
Vietnam and so it was this kind of
unifying force this is true in the
United States also in 1968 was a very
divisive moment in the civil rights
movement when snick Student Nonviolent
Coordinating Committee was giving up a
non-violence and there was a split
between people like Stokely Carmichael
and people like Martin Luther King
Stokely Carmichael was a man who you
know had spent ten years in nonviolent
activism getting his life threatened
getting beaten up getting thrown in jail
and had just had it 1968 was the year of
the emergence of black power and there
was this tremendous disagreement about
the future of the civil rights movement
between the nonviolent wing and the
black power wing although they respected
each other much more than as is now said
Martin Luther King wholly spoke well of
Stokely Carmichael and Stokely
Carmichael always spoke well of Martin
Luther King but it was very difficult to
do actions together because there was
this complete disagreement on tactics
but the one thing that they all agreed
on was opposition to the war in Vietnam
and so that the globally or around the
world the Vietnam War served as almost a
vehicle of protest the the other thing
that was really unique and remarkable
about the year 1968 is that it happened
to be at a very special time in the
history of the evolution of television
in fact the evolution of society in
general 1968 in 1968 people had this
sense that they were on the edge of a
new world that everything was going to
be different and it was different but it
wasn't different in the way very few
people imagined the only person I know
of who in 1968 understood exactly the
way the world was changing was Marshall
McLuhan and you go back and you read
Marshall McLuhan and it's just
absolutely amazing he saw it all how
politics were going to change and how
communications and the way people
related that we were on me they were we
were on the edge of the dawn of an age
of television and technology most of us
didn't understand that but we lived it a
couple of important things had happened
in television one was satellite
transmission satellites making it
possible to have live transmissions the
first live satellite transmission was in
1958 but for a very long time you could
only do a satellite transmission from a
certain place at a certain time to a
certain place at a certain time
depending on where in relationship to
the earth the satellite was so that
Daniel Schorr told me this story of how
this is when he worked for CBS and CBS
realized that in this certain week
the satellite would be in a position so
that if he were at the Berlin Wall at
midnight he could broadcast live to the
Cronkite show in New York the only
problem was that there was absolutely
nothing going on at the Berlin Wall at
midnight so he stood in front of the
Berlin Wall and you know Walter Here I
am in Berlin and as you can see it's
very dark and you hear those dogs
barking they they may be barking at
people trying to jump the wall or or
maybe not had absolutely nothing to say
but it was it was very exciting because
it was live you know live from Berlin
they by 1968 they have figured out
geostationary satellites that stay in
the same position relative to the earth
so that you could at any time of day
from any place you could broadcast live
to any other place the other big thing
was the change from film to video video
is first of all much cheaper than film
and you can reshoot it so cameras now
can just keep running but you couldn't
afford to do that with film if if this
were film I would have to say something
dramatic to get him to turn on the
camera but since its since its video he
can just roll it it was a huge change in
the way news was covered but also film
has to be processed in video doesn't and
just shoot it and then broadcast it
there were a number of at least four
television broadcasts in 1968 that are
among
the pivotal moments in the history of
television the first of which was the
Tet Offensive Tet was the Vietnamese new
year and a very curious thing that
Vietnam had a very long history of
warfare centuries of warfare and during
those centuries of warfare they very
frequently did surprise attacks during
Tet and yet somehow they did it again
and everybody was once again surprised
battles in Vietnam correspondents would
have to get some ride in some military
vehicle up north somewhere where the
battle was taking place and cover it and
then get back to Saigon and ship the
film but the Tet Offensive took place in
Saigon and very dramatically at the US
Embassy in Saigon US Embassy in Saigon
was in the neighborhood where all of the
journalists not only lived but filed
their stories from so from from the
standpoint of transmitting stories you
know the Vietcong could not have picked
a better location to attack and this
stuff was just very quickly turned
around and with the the time difference
between Vietnam and the United States
every day that day's battle was on
television at night which may not strike
you as any big deal but had never been
done before and in 1968 this was you
know a shocking and an extraordinary
thing to see warfare for the first time
on film and had all kinds of
ramifications there was a film in 1968
called the Green Berets that John Wayne
directed and starred in and almost every
critic in the country
regarded this as one of the worst movies
ever made and I mean if you've ever seen
it there's there's lots of reasons why
you might think that but one of the
things that almost every critic singled
out was that it didn't look anything
like the war in Vietnam I mean there
were no black soldiers for one tank the
landscape didn't look like Vietnam
nothing looked like Vietnam so you have
this situation where you know here is
the war movie and here is the war and
they don't look the same and it became a
huge shift in how war was was portrayed
by by Hollywood it happened to coincide
with a change in encodes with the with
the rating system we have now which
allowed more violence if you rated it
accordingly because there was no way
that you could have war movies without
this violence when everybody was
watching it on television and of course
the other important thing was that the
war that everybody was watching on
television was not going the way Lyndon
Johnson and the military and everybody
was telling us it was going and it was
the beginning maybe not the beginning I
mean some correspondence had long before
that but it became very clear to
correspondence that you know the way to
cover war was not the way was done in
World War two the way to cover war was
not to rely on the military command and
the US government for information but to
see what was going on in the field and
to get that information out I wish that
journalists today would study the
coverage of the Vietnam War because we
were able to get a pretty good idea of
what was happening in Vietnam and you
know we don't have a clue of what's
happening in a
in Afghanistan another really pivotal
television broadcast was the riots
outside the Democratic convention in
Chicago in August and I remember
watching them on TV and thinking how
remarkable this was not that they were
happening because every demonstration I
had been in had ended up in violence and
it to people who demonstrated against
the war it was a you know an accepted
thing that this is how it ended up but
that it was on television and was still
going on while it was on television that
you know people were sitting there in
their living room and including people
who didn't go to anti-war demonstrations
and they're there watching this violence
while it's happening
it just had a huge impact and at almost
the same time the Soviet invasion of
Czechoslovakia Czechoslovakia was was
one of the most important things that
happened in 1968 in the very beginning
of the year in January Alexander Dubcek
came to power a man that people didn't
know very much about who had been a
lifelong communist and he was he was
very silent actually at first when he
hit into power and nobody knew what was
going to go on and he began he started
becoming responsive to student movements
and things that we're going on in
Czechoslovakia and creating this society
that was that was actually much more
like what Marx had written about a
communist society that was that was open
and had a Free Press and had freedom of
expression and there was tremendous
excitement in a world that was not very
happy with the way the West was going
and was not very happy with the way the
communist bloc was going tremendous
excitement about this other alternative
that communism could be
this this other very positive thing and
then it was just absolutely crushed by
Brezhnev and it was really the beginning
of the end of the Soviet Union and
Gorbachev years later said that because
this was a movement of communists there
was a poll in 1968 over 90 percent the
people in Czechoslovakia wanted the
country to remain communist
it wasn't about overthrowing communism
at all and they regarded themselves as
good allies of the Soviet Union and and
you know one of the central beliefs of
communism is that you keep perfecting
society you keep working towards change
to make a better society and suddenly it
was realized that the Soviet Union would
accept absolutely no change that took
away the best reason for being a
communist the Soviets debated a long
time about making this move and when
they finally decided to do it they had a
plan in which they were going to tell
the world that the Dubcek government had
gone too far and the people of
Czechoslovakia were trying to overthrow
it and had asked for the Soviets to come
in and help them the problem was
television it was all on television and
the and the film was smuggled out of the
country and people all over the world
saw unarmed Czechs facing Soviet and
Warsaw Pact tanks and that film footage
was really the beginning of the end of
the Soviet bloc and the other the other
really startling television event of 68
was Apollo 8 which went to the moon John
Kennedy in the beginning of the decade
had said that by the end of the decade
the US would go to the moon and that was
you know that seemed like a hundred
years ago in another age an age before
assassinations and before the Gulf of
Tonkin and before the Vietnam
or an age of optimism that was lost but
now it was the end of the decade and we
were going to go to the moon and now
they're exploring Mars right now I think
this is incredible but nobody really
seems to care all that much but you know
people were really excited about this
going to the moon and they broadcast
from the far side of the Moon television
and this was just this stunning end to
the horrible year the last week of the
year live broadcast from the moon it was
a terrible year I still when I think
back I still feel the pain I feel pain
when I think about Martin Luther King
murdered
I think if Bobby Kennedy murdered it was
like the death of hope 15,000 Americans
died in Vietnam that year alone and
several hundred thousand Vietnamese were
killed by them in what the US government
said was building democracy 1 million
children starved to death in Biafra a
tribal state that tried to break away
from Nigeria and the Nigerian government
was unable to defeat them militarily but
was able to put a blockade around so
that food wouldn't go in and so they all
starved and the US government wouldn't
break the blockade to bring in food
because they said that they didn't want
to interfere in a civil war in another
country it was a terrible year and yet I
think a lot of people look back on it
with nostalgia and there are a number of
reasons for that
one of them is that it was a kind of a
wonderfully wacky sardonic time you know
they used to take tour groups to the
East Village in New York to look at
hippies and they go down 8th Street say
Marx and you know photograph and look
out the window and there be a tour guide
there is a you know on your right you
will see the hippies and and one day the
people in the East Village got tired of
this and they they rented a bus and they
went to Queens and they would go up to
people and say excuse me sir why are you
mowing your lawn
I mean that was 68 also and 68 in a way
was a wonderfully literary time it was a
time when poetry and poets mattered
Allen Ginsberg and Robert Lowell and
Yevtushenko
and Robert Lowell used to campaign with
gene McCarthy and more people ran up to
Lowell than than McCarthy McCarthy got
sick of that and about halfway through
the year in mid campaign announced that
he was a poet and came out with three
poems of his own the poetry was
everywhere rock bands were named you
know the doors were named after a
passage from Blake and Steppenwolf was
from HESA and it was a great time for
theater it was the time of fossil of
Havel
in Prague and great German theater
marat/sade and Rosencrantz and
Guildenstern and Julian back and a
really exciting time but I think I think
that the most important reason why 1968
is look back on with nostalgia is
because it was a time when people felt
they had a voice
that they could change the world maybe
they could at least try and if you
didn't have anything else available to
you you could just go out on the street
and scream and maybe a hundred thousand
people would scream with you and maybe
something would happen and you weren't
helpless and in an odd sort of way it
was a great age of optimism I travel
around this country a lot now and
everywhere I go I talked to a remarkably
wide range of people different ages and
clearly different politics but a lot of
people who don't like what this country
is doing they don't like where it's
going and and they feel helpless they
feel that there's nothing that they can
do and for those people I think
sixty-eight has a great lesson there are
things that can be done you know when
young people are sent out to die instead
of being educated and the planet is
being stripped and corporations are
running roughshod over our life there's
work to be done and there are things to
be done and there are ways of doing it I
just want to end with a quote from Camus
some of you may remember that in 1968
everybody quoted Camus Robert Kennedy
did Tom Hayden did Danny Cohen bendy did
so I want to quote my favorite Camus
in 1968 I didn't have to wear glasses to
do this the longing for rest and peace
must itself be thrust aside it coincides
with the acceptance of iniquity those
who weep for the happy periods they
encountered in history acknowledge what
they want not the alleviation but the
silencing of misery thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you I'd love to take questions
from anybody but please step up to the
mic over there I'm just gonna can you um
confirm or refute this I've heard a
bunch of historians talk about Nixon
before Johnson dropped out was secretly
contacted he was in communication with
Hanoi attempting them to delay a peace
deal so he could sort of keep it a very
much a political issue in the election
is that is that junk history or is that
I don't I I don't know I've never seen
any convincing evidence of that it could
be true in hindsight it was completely
unnecessary the Paris peace talks
weren't making any progress at all
Hubert Humphrey campaign whenever he was
asked what he was going to do about the
war in Vietnam he merrily said you know
Humphrey have this weirdly merry way of
talking and he would say say oh I I
don't have to worry about that that'll
be all over by the time I'm in the White
House
but in fact there was no progress being
made so I I don't know I mean I've heard
those stories I've never seen any
evidence of that in trying to explain
why the events of 1968 occurred in 1968
could you mention maybe the coming of
age of the baby boomers as having an
influence there yeah
sure it did not least of all because it
meant that there were an enormous number
of people going to college and colleges
especially in Europe were becoming very
overcrowded which was leading to a lot
of student dissatisfaction this in fact
was a major issue in most European
universities was the overcrowding yeah
sure so what happened
I remember 68 there were different
values I remember money was bad the army
was bad drugs were good
no but seriously if people were trying
we're looking differently for a
different value system non consumerist
value system and there were a lot of
people think it seemed like everybody
was on the left then what what happened
well first of all everybody wasn't on
the left that's part of the problem you
know one of the great lessons from 68
which came as such a surprise to all of
us but shouldn't have been is that if
you decide to try to change the world
the people who are controlling the world
are going to be pretty ruthless about
stopping you and in the United States
Richard Nixon completely reconfigured
politics and reconstructed a different
Republican Party I mean the Republican
Party of 1968 would be unrecognizable as
Republicans today destroyed the liberal
wing of the party and fashioned a
a type of politics that we still see
from the Republican Party today that's
based on fear and it was a very smart
thing that he did because there was a
lot of fear in 68 a lot of people just
fearing that things were going to just
spin out of control and the code word
for repression was law and order and
there was this this tremendous response
to these these these appeals of fear
because you know cities were burning and
a lot of things were happening that
people just didn't know where it was all
all going in a tremendous created a
tremendous insecurity but it's not that
nothing you know there were no positive
results that it produced the feminist
movement for one thing it produced many
positive things all over the world
that took a very long time to to be seen
but it just I'm sorry the revolution
didn't happen it's true how has our
understanding of the lessons and
significance of 1968 changed from the
world before 9/11 to the post 9/11 world
today well I mean I I have a view of
this that I I don't know you know how
many people agree with my view of it but
I think that the really big thing that
happened post 9/11 was the way it has
been manipulated by the government
and the way it has been used to promote
war to curb civil rights and I think
that in the doing of those things people
have started thinking again about 68
about stopping war about protecting
civil rights and about the things that
were done in 68 to try to do that a few
years ago I came into a book I can't
remember the title or author by a French
woman about the way that 1968 has been
downplayed throughout throughout the
years and turned into a bunch of
dissatisfied youths and the you know the
true challenging revolutionary character
of 68 has been whitewashed and there's
been to some extent you know the end of
the Cold War has been turned into a
vindication of the right-wing forces who
at the time were pro Vietnam and there's
a zero acknowledgment which is strange
because the whole point of you know all
of these student movements all over the
world you know I mean go back read the
Port Huron Statement of the SDS you know
it's what everybody wanted to do was
stop the Cold War uh-huh I think the
Cold War was you know it it was the
great obstacles for peace in the world
and one of the things that all these
movements which were trying to stop yeah
I mean one of the things that that
bothers me is that it tried there's an
effort to reduce it to rock and roll you
know as though that the the big thing
that happened in the in in 1968 was Jimi
Hendrix
I love Jimi Hendrix but you know all
these things and and there were
tremendous things that happened in rock
music and in pop through music in 68 but
these things were a reaction to what was
going on it's not as though you know the
things that were going on were a
reaction to the music
they're also from the moment Martin
Luther King died he has been resurrected
as this false
you know fantasy saint
instead of instead of the rebel that he
was he was at Martin Luther King was a
wonderful rebel and a great dissident
voice and and and his you know been been
turned into this tool of the
establishment that he never was people
rewrite history all the time yes sir my
name is Brian and I want to thank you
very much for being here I'm very much
looking forward to reading the book you
mentioned Hubert Humphrey earlier and
his story has always been part of my
fascination with 1968 when I was in
college I wrote a paper about the
relationship or lack thereof between his
presidential campaign and young people
and I was struck by the sort of the
tragic character arc of someone who is
such a bright progressive star the
Democratic Party in 48 and 20 years
later seemed to have zero credibility
whatsoever with this new generation and
I'm curious what were your memories
didn't mean to do fee I know you're a
year away from my guest voting age in 68
but you feel it all engaged by him or no
any any hope whatsoever
no none I have no idea said it was a
year away and I couldn't vote and I'm
grateful for that
because I have no idea what I would have
done Humphrey and Nixon were to me
two totally unacceptable candidates and
infer NCA today well the biggest issue
was the Vietnam War and they were
undifferentiated on that issue
they weren't offering anything different
Humphrey also did a lot of strange
things in an attempt to steal Nixon
votes try to applaud it daily for the
attack on demonstrators in Chicago and
tried to say that you know the
demonstrators deserve to be beaten up
because they used foul language which is
weird from a man who had spent years
working side-by-side with Lyndon Johnson
one of history's notorious potty-mouth
but yeah I mean Johnson had was Humphrey
was very much associated with Johnson
and had no credit of credibility to
certainly the anti-war movement in the
student movement in 68 and and yet
almost one came very close
Nixon was considered an unelectable
politician and you know only only a
Democrat that had as much negative
baggage as Hubert Humphrey could have
possibly lost him being a former Maoist
which have been saying leads me to
remember Mao tse-tung's saying that
history's like a boiling pot for decades
it may everything may be beneath the
surface and nothing appears but then all
of a sudden in one year or in a few
years decades occur and that's what
happened in 1968 basically four or five
ten years occurred in that one year in a
net decade you could say decades
occurred in the 60s in terms of things
being uh yeah and and you know I think
there may be a lot of things going on
now that people don't see there were
millions who demonstrated against the
war in Iraq there are a lot of things
going on a lot of it isn't that easy to
see because it's not on the street it's
in the Internet Tom Hayden said to me
that in the early 1960s when he was a
student at University of Michigan and he
was the editor of the Michigan daily he
went out to California and he wrote
these stories about student movements
and all of these counterculture things
that were going on and he got back to
Ann Arbor and all of the his faculty
advisors said why are you making up this
stuff none of this is happening it took
about two years more before you know
everybody saw that these things were
happening let me make one other comment
which is about you're talking about a
lot of good things were done and I feel
in the 50s 60s and 70s is basically the
greatest democratic movement in American
history you figure nineteen fifty women
have the right to vote but essentially
no other rights african-americans had no
rights Latinos asian-americans lesbians
and gays handicaps now we're talking
sixty to eighty percent of the
population of America gained huge rights
in those decades we should be very proud
what we accomplished in those years yeah
but we need to accomplish more the far
right far better what we didn't we do hi
I'm Bianca and I haven't read your book
yet but being a PR professional I was
interested in your whole theory about
you know live television making such a
huge difference and I was 15 in 1968 so
I was surprised did I get this right I
guess I read it in a review that this
was the first year they had live TV
because I thought it was before there
were the first live broadcast was in 58
it was a statement by Eisenhower no but
I mean the regular watching of the war
on TV and yeah yeah most of it was not
live most of it was instant replay but
yeah it was the four it was the first
year of live and of regularly seeing
events that either were happening or had
just happened because I would think that
that would have really contributed to
the whole anti-war movement most
certainly did it absolutely did and one
of the things that has really I've
gotten to be hideously cynical you know
I remember back then I was you know
would March an anti-war marches even at
that age but I would still believe in
the government you know or think that we
could do things in the country wasn't
horrible having a tough time today and
you know because now if it's not on TV
it didn't happen somehow had a hard time
seeing how the Internet's gonna make
that switch well you know television did
a lot of useful things in 1968 because
it was new and hadn't learned how to
package itself and thank God right now
well we have to find other ways of doing
that yeah okay well thank you look
forward to reading it thanks one of the
takes on the on the period in 1968 that
I've had and I'd enjoy hearing your
comments on it to some degree I see that
there was what I would term a
transformation of idealism
that sort of came to a head in 1968 from
my perception of course the the Kennedy
years were over the decline through the
through the Johnson years the
assassination of Martin Luther King who
held a certain element of idealism and
even things even things in my own case I
was in the Foreign Service in working
for the US Agency for International
Development in Nigeria during this
period and one of them to be Afrin or
yes exactly and one of the senses that I
had over there and he had it when I came
back to the States off and on during
that same year was that the idealism of
Africa the hopes for Nigeria the great
writers of show Janka and HIV and these
people were kind of dashed by by the
tribalism and again essentially the war
so yeah maybe the emotional
psychological impact of the be offering
war because as you say I mean Nigeria
was one of the new emerging nations that
had that that people had the greatest
hopes for and you know this too was was
on TV and in the media and we all saw
these starving children every day and it
had a huge psychological effect on
people all over the world so in a sense
just generally in 68 my sense of it was
that much of the idealism of earlier in
the decade I had run into great
difficulty in seeing it played out and
and and progress being made and there
was a certain degree of reaction to it
that the hopelessness of the situation
which led as a matter of fact I made a
note when you were talking about the
poets well here's one thing you have in
in popular culture the musical hair with
the first nudity that I ever saw on the
stage and one believably 1968 right
before that
the culture that I was more feeling you
know Raisin in the Sun to kill a
mockingbird more serious and less of a
kind of frustrated lashing out at things
that were well I mean there was a lot of
really serious of theater at 68 my hair
was you know what was hair about it was
about everything yeah it was part of
this whole thing of let's try to find
out what the hippies are doing thank you
thank you my name is Joe Fisher
thank you very much enjoyed your
reminiscence of that year you raised the
issue of Mark Rudd that you talked to
him recently and I'm quite curious and
as time is going by and he reflects on
what he did and where he did it and the
enormous damage that was done to
Columbia University does he have any of
any regrets at all about maybe picking
that particular place for bringing the
kind of conflict that decisions that
were made and the enormous damage it was
done to that University well I hate to
be put in the position of speaking for
him but I have talked extensively to him
about these things and and my impression
is is that he has a lot of regrets about
the post 68 period the Weathermen period
but not know really about Columbia it
was felt that Columbia was a university
that I don't know that it was damaged I
think was changed for the better I I
talked to I know a lot of people who
teach at Columbia now and I enlarged
they're glad it happened
Columbia where it was it was was an
absolutely stopped applying place in
1968 and was very deeply involved in in
in the American Vietnam war machine and
was not you know mark Rudd went to
Columbia thinking that it was the
the castle on the hill where people
debated ideas and intellectualism and
found that you know it was all about
money and real estate and then and
developing weapons and well I've done
I'm getting trapped into speaking for
him and I heard that I've said enough in
the voice of Mark Rutte one last other
question obviously many at the time in
1968 vilified Lyndon Johnson I mean I
remember the chance and so forth I was
coming like duty at the time when I was
back here in Washington again with the
passage of time when they go back and
they reflect on his presidency they have
some reassessment I mean my own sons was
as the Johnson more than any President
had a firm a commitment in his bones as
a southerner as a politician to making
achieving racial justice which he did in
pushing through the 64 Civil Rights Act
in the 1965 Voting Rights Act which I
think we're really where the keys that
were handed to the Republicans to ioj to
the dark angels to the south yeah I I I
would tend to agree with you personally
though I have no regrets about trying to
stop the killing that he was unleashing
thank you for your comments and in your
book and it's been especially
interesting tonight having some somebody
else who was in the middle of all this
to hear what other people of the same
age where we're feeling at the moment
but I wanted to make a comment and then
ask a question related to that in 1968 I
was I was I had been a grunt in the
civil rights movement and I was getting
involved in the anti-war movement today
I'm still sort of a paid organizer for
many national organizations and in the
course of the course of my work in the
last 20 or 30 years I've traveled around
the country a lot as you said you've
done and talked to many people and at
the risk of sounding too optimistic in a
hard time I've come to the conclusion
the last 10 years that busy as it was
exciting as it was in 1967 68 69 even 70
for those of us who are there my feeling
talking particularly to young people on
campuses and you know Democratic Party
activists and even Republican Party
activists you know in various parts of
the country is that there's a million
times more people working on the issues
that we care about in nineteen nineteen
sixty-eight then there were then I think
that the thing that I have felt and I
wonder if you agree with us or not is
that 1968 was real important in so many
ways because the great unifying thing
was being against the war so you felt if
you went to an anti-war demonstration if
you went to any kind of a meeting the
war always came up and there was this
unifying thing where you could see who
your allies were now that's not so it's
it's sort of true of the Iraq war but
it's not as true but I find what if I
look at the environmental movement and
the anti-sweatshop movement boy there's
a million more people especially people
in their 20s and 30s millions more who
are really involved engaged in every way
more than you know no III don't spend a
lot of time on college campuses but I
have been on a few of late and it's my
impression that young people college
students are being very underrated but
there's a lot of them who really do care
about issues and are passionate about
these things and prepared to do things
about them and I think it's I think
they're being very underestimated yeah
and I think given what some people have
said about you know what's happened and
being under the radar screen I think
these are the kids who are under the
radar screen now who are doing really
major work on you know the globalization
issue sweatshop issues all these kinds
of things big big time environmental
stuff and that there may be some sort of
a major positive explosion in the coming
years of these people i I agree with you
I just want to sneak this last guy in
because I'm over my limit and he's the
last guy and I want to hear what he has
to say well you may not want to actually
you know you could we rerun the table if
I don't like it just a footnote I was
attracted out to Hubert Humphrey and
went to work for him when I was still in
my 20s precisely because he was for
civil rights and a very courageous
person with positions of the issues long
before Jean McCarthy and Bobby Kennedy
came along I was with him in the
convention I wrote his acceptance speech
I was I can still smell the stench of
the tear gas it's a bad time while we
have a clear consensus of Vietnam and
what could have been done and should
have been done every every survey that's
been taken shows that if he had moved
sooner than he did and more courageously
than he did left he would have lost the
election worse than he did he came with
an eyelash of winning and if he had won
that election can there be any doubt
that this country would be a better
country if we had not had Richard Nixon
for those four years and the Watergate
that followed so in a life a time of
realism when you have only two choices
to make the question is which was what
we better off with so I just want to
leave that small note that despite the
the sense of loss of hope of that time
it was a pretty difficult experience to
go through in terms of trying to get
where we wanted to get I'll leave it at
that to them thank you
[Applause]
marker Lansky is author of cod salt and
the Basque history of the world
his latest 1968 the year that rocked the
world is published by Ballantine Books
visit Random House calm /bb
for more information next week on
history on book TV Geoffrey Kimble on
the Vietnam War files